[Musique]
d'abord de la part de toute l'équipe
j'aimerais vous souhaiter une très belle
année 2021 je commence avec une question
est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé de
vous faire arrêter
interpellé par la police comme ça pour
rien juste pour contrôler votre identité
et moi jamais malheureusement d'autres
pans des routes
c'est un peu le truc de pavlov dit aux
pieds noirs voitures luxueuses pablo
escobar
suite l'attention à un point la
communication entre les polices et les
autochtones c'est un gag qui comme comme
le guardian kent
savez-vous depuis combien de temps on
parle de profilage racial par la police
de montréal
puis 40 % de leur temps sont noirs et à
chaque dérapage la police promet de
changer tout en faisant la même chose
multiplier des pratiques policières qui
mène à de la discrimination c'est une
agente elle est venue à ma fenêtre et
m'a demandé
ce que je faisais parce que ce que je
vendais pour avoir une belle voiture
comme ça ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
c'était chu dont je suis morrison soirée
débat bosse dur et h 30 à la maison
pelle soirée jeux j'ai fait de bonnes
blagues de bonne humeur
j'oublie quelque chose dans ma voiture
je vais chercher je suis dans ma voiture
côté passager moins d'une minute et
j'entends très fort bougent pas ils
avaient acheté des aurait aimé qu'ils
avaient oublié dans le loto pétanque je
suis forcée dans l'auto et pendant que
je suis penché en premier les prendre
dans l'auto une voiture de police arrête
à côté de moi et flash et lumière non
moi c'est notamment champion un gars qui
avait fait deux reprises dans son goût
avec moi je comprends pas pourquoi
samuel plus tard il ya quelqu'un
vergogne pointé sur moi
là il commença à être sur la défensive
et puis elle commence à enfiler leurs
dents puis je demander quand vous voulez
mais papier mais c'est à la maison je
peux pas vous donner des papiers que
j'ai pas là mon permis que j'ai pas les
audi quand ça à mettre la force 3 mètres
la force moyenne contre le véhicule le
bras au cou je suis même pas conscient
que j'ai des bras comme ça mais son
pagne lui il me dit best et brad pitt
j'arrive pas dit j'arrive pas une note
elle-même est nativement femmes dans
l'auto puis il me laisse pas le temps
avec une amende
plus de 400 dollars ps je vous parle je
m'en souviens encore ça la raison
pourquoi ils m'ont interpellé à il
disait qu' il y avait beaucoup de vols
de véhicules dans le coin ces histoires
vous surprennent peut-être à moins
qu'elle est un air de déjà vu
ça dépend de la couleur de votre peau
pour ceux et celles qui les vivent
elles sont la démonstration que le
racisme systémique existe dans la police
le gouvernement legault n'y crois pas si
je prends la définition systémique de
dire un système au québec
le système chez les policiers dans la
fonction publique est un système qu'on
lit minorités visibles des mouches pas
d'accord avec ça pourtant le chef du
service de police de la ville de
montréal là nous nous reconnaissons
également qu'il existe des disparités
dans les interpellations policières
causés par baby assister mais le chef
car ont annoncé ce jour là une nouvelle
mesure pour contrer le profilage racial
bien mal reçue par les communautés
racisées parce que depuis 40 ans
la police a échoué à éliminer le
profilage au contraire après chaque
tragédie de nouvelles pratiques ont
accentué le problème
[Applaudissements]
attention ces images sont d'une cruauté
insoutenable 25 mai de l'es20 john floyd
meurt sous le genou d'un policier à
minneapolis
le racisme de l'intervention soulève
l'indignation partout à montréal
ils sont des milliers à descendre dans
la rue pour des os et de gestion active
pour l'avocat fernando bel temps le
racisme systémique est une bataille
quotidienne
l'analyse de la preuve est extrêmement
importante et ça vaut beaucoup plus dans
la balance que si c'était moi qui disait
que les policiers son bac revue servando
a fondé la clinique juridique de saint
michel en 2018 autour de la table
l'ex stagiaire en droit on se penche sur
des cas de profilage racial
voir quelqu'un mourir sous mes yeux
moralement en agonie pendant si
longtemps entouré surtout deux collègues
policiers qui sont là ils étaient quatre
donc on a une personne un agent qui
décident d'agir mal et tous les autres
en fait qui se soutiennent entre eux
déjà là ça nous fait comprendre que la
police sera jamais de la solution au
profilage racial parce que il ya une
stratégie temps la police qui rend
impossible pour un policier de ce lever
de se dire de briser lui même la chaîne
certains diront qu ici au québec
les relations entre la police les
personnes assises et sont tout autres
fernando n'est pas de cet avis sa
clinique a organisé une sorte de
marathon sur les réseaux sociaux et
récolté des dizaines de témoignages de
profilage racial
avec la complicité de l'humoriste et
militant antiraciste rennwald ashington
quentinois les panneaux dits y en a des
racines se débrouiller wax c'est une
façon de dire on a toujours entendu
l'histoire de la bouche des autres c320
nous-mêmes raconter notre propre
histoire
entre nous c'est pour nous une façon de
lens vous pensez que ça existe pas on va
vous donner une preuve irréfutable que
ça existe nous avons nous aussi invité
ces gens à briser le tabou entourant le
profilage je dois chaque fois que je
vois un policier tout de suite je
m'attends à ce qu'ils m'arrêtent tout de
suite et je dirais 60% des cas ça ne
loupe pas dès un jeune âge mes parents
disent
et vers l'école apprend une profession
devient quelqu'un de sérieux et je me
rends compte maintenant que malgré tous
ces bons conseils malgré le fait que je
les ai suivis je me retrouve quand même
dans la mer ni policier pour une raison
que je les ignore
tu te fais arrêter devant chez vous plus
en demande si c'est devant chez toi je
sais pas si ça arrive aux blancs non
[Musique]
ces témoignages font écho aux résultats
d'une étude réalisée par des chercheurs
indépendants sur les interpellations
policières à montréal l'interpellation
est un simple contrôle d'identité parce
qu'une interpellation en une prise de
renseignements donc l insu de laquelle
n'y a pas de sanction en cas pas de
faute reconnue donc le personnes qui se
font interpeller les relâcher les codes
interpellé donne des renseignements et
ensuite elle s'en va de 2014 à 2017
le nombre d'interpellations a augmenté
de 143 % à montréal les noirs les arabes
et les autochtones sont interpellés de 4
à 5 fois plus souvent que blanc les
résultats de l'étude détruisent un mythe
tenace
donc on a essayé de se dire est ce que
ça pourrait s'expliquer par le fait que
certains groupes comme est plus de crème
et donc forcément ils sont plus
interpellés et donc on a analysé ça et
se rend compte que cette balle qu'à
l'interpellation les vues par la police
comme un outil de prévention du crime ni
pour prévoir le crime les policiers ont
besoin de se faire une idée de ce que
représente un criminel potentiel
c'est là le danger ya des gens qui
effectivement sont jeunes sont noires
portent un hoodie une casquette et
conduisent une voiture relativement
luxueuse et eux c'est le combo le mix
qui va donner lieu à un certain nombre
d'interprétations et c'est ça et c'est
un problème c'est un vrai problème ces
gens là ils n'ont pas à subir ça cette
époque j'avais une mercedes c 300 sauts
je passe de l'autre côté je vois que le
policier il m'a vu il fait le tour
complètement en effet un gros your turn
et il vient se coller derrière moi la
première chose qui me demandent ces ihu
allez vous comme ça vous êtes donc bien
chic
anna aux laïcs je vais je m'habille
comme ça tous les jours
puis il m'a dit ah ouais je croyais que
vous alliez un match donc c'est ton
véhicule réduit puis l'a même dit
comment tu l'as pays c'est une agente
elle est venue à ma fenêtre et m'a
demandé ce que je faisais ce que ce que
je vendais pour avoir une belle voiture
comme ça à l'époque j'avais une jolie
voiture je m'étais fait plaisir je
mettais déjà fait demander qu'est ce que
tu fais dans la vie pour avoir une belle
voiture comme ça avec qu'est ce que tu
avances j'étais un peu fâché la question
puis là il me dit tu ont permis un
permis étranger est ce que tu es
étudiant j'ai dit oui je suis étudiant
est ce que vous voulez que je vous
montre ma facture des colis peut-être
donc je vous montre la preuve qu'il ya
un revirement qui a été fait est là il
commence à me poser d'autres questions
et y ton père et fais quoi dans la vie
elle m'a demandé de sortir du véhicule
plage là je me rappelle me dis ok ouais
là c'est réel c'est sérieux à la vider
mon sac sur le sur le le capot de la
voiture
elle a vu maccabi d'antiquités accroché
à lens de mon sac est toujours là et
elle s'est rendu compte que j'étais en
fait médecin que je travaille à
l'hôpital puis elle m'a tendu ma carte
mon cinquième est mort elle même à
souhaiter une bonne soirée comme si de
rien n'était c'est en plein milieu de la
rue tous mes et fait son retour au sol
sur la soie watts heure c'est humiliant
[Musique]
depuis des années des voix s'élèvent
pour dénoncer les interpellations
abusives
elles sont vécues comme une forme de
détention psychologique
il y en a beaucoup que ce n'est plus une
expérience unique
il y en a beaucoup comme on a vu lors du
marathon qui le vivent jour après jour
année après année décennie après
décennie des gens qu'ils écoutent j'ai
été interpellé plus que cent fois dans
ma vie tout essayé de trouver des
personnes blanches qui sont capables de
raconter ce genre d'expérience à ça
existe presque par la most en que j'ai
nos styles jaune salines
je laime c'est mon véhicule j'ai payé je
me levais le matin à 6 heures pour aller
travailler à l'autobus dans le
centre-ville
j'ai gagné mon véhicule j'ai le droit de
le conduire c'est qu'il a des mac 20
pouces que ça soit une batterie que ça
soit lemken l'homme noir a le droit de
conduire son véhicule n'est pas obligé
d'avoir un toyota corolla pour la
première fois une organisation policière
québécoise j'ai encadré une
interpellation une activité réalisé
quotidiennement par les patrouilleurs la
nouvelle politique sur les
interpellations policières risque de ne
pas suffire à stopper le profilage
racial
le problème est beaucoup plus profond et
n'est pas seulement le fait de quelques
policiers fautifs
c'était juste le fait de quelques
individus mal intentionnés bah ça serait
assez facile à régler comme problème
vous avez qu à les identifier
j'allais mettre dehors et il y en aurait
plus de racisme y aurait plus de
discrimination le fait que ce soit aussi
durable ou si un répandue que ce soit
aussi systématiquement retrouver c'est
bien la preuve que le problème c'est pas
le quelques individus mal intentionnés
mais que c'est un racisme qui est
systémique c'est à dire que c'est le
système qui produit lancé la manière
d'un système fonctionne
[Musique]
quand on jette un coup d'oeil dans le
passé on voit comment même en évoluant
le système n'a pas cessé de produire des
pratiques discriminatoires
[Musique]
après la pause on va vous montrer que le
profilage racial à montréal ça ne date
pas d'hier
comment un policier peut-il avoir à ce
point la gâchette légère
[Musique]
on entendu plusieurs personnes noires
raconté que dès l'enfance
leurs parents les ont éduqué à faire
très attention dans leurs interactions
avec la police ces conseils viennent pas
de nulle part
ils viennent d'une longue trop longue
expérience
[Applaudissements]
premièrement méfie 12 et déplacé
sentiment que la solidarité qu'on a ici
mais ne seront pas s'étonner qu'une
ville a converti un changement mais
madame fallait continuer mon père et moi
je suis partie des victoires stéphanie
germain fait elle aussi partie de cette
génération de jeunes qui refusent le
statu quo c'est quelque chose qu'on
oublie c'est que le racisme dessus c'est
sûr qu'on peut pas rester indifférent ce
parce qu'on a vécu aussi pour le vit au
quotidien sur 1,6 me ça fait partie de
notre quotidien
juste à cause des paroles de foot et
puis je trouve que tu ne peux pas alors
que dans son lit
quoi qu'on pense à la mort de floyd ne
peut ne pas penser à fredy villanueva
abonnés jean-pierre à marseille françois
à toutes ces personnes qui ont perdu la
vie entre les mains des forces
policières
donc évidemment que ça ramène des
traumas qu'est ce qui a changé
on les appelle les boat people de l'air
fin des années 70 montréal accueille 100
migrants a lissé par semaine qui suit le
régime brutal de dj il serait
actuellement environ 2000 haïtiens à
vivre et légalement au québec
l'enquêteur spécial du gouvernement du
québec estime qu'on ne peut humainement
les renvoyer dans leur pays
cette vague migratoire n'est pas la
première mais elle marque le début de la
lutte des noirs contre le profilage
racial à montréal le premier jalon de
cette lutte survient le 20 juin 1979
des policiers matraques quatre jeunes
noirs qui jouent au soccer dans un parc
parce qu'ils auraient été trop bruyants
ils ont dit au jeune con con que la
police allait les matins fort dimanche
qu'ils étaient les prisons 1 de duvalier
qui torturaient allégeant la police les
lui a dit qu il allait lui l'on sait à
travers le pont champlain à lui noyé
dans le pleure
un policier admet avoir frappé un des
adolescents la tête sont raison mais ce
sont les victimes qui finiront par être
récusé les quatre accusés ont plaidé non
coupable aujourd'hui en cour municipale
à diverses accusations allant de l'
entrave au travail d'un policier à
l'évasion d'une garde légale la
communauté noire dénonce un racisme
larvé au sein des policiers les
autorités rejettent l'accusation mais la
ville est condamné à une amende
dérisoire de 500 $ pour les paroles
racistes proférées lors de l'incident
c'est un premier rendez vous manqué
parce qu'il faut leur ouvrage point noir
blanc jaune des couleurs je vois
vraiment pas le choix pour
discrimination au niveau et d'un la
police joie que ça peut être tendu à
l'occasion puisse est appelée à être
toujours tendu je pense pas que ça
vienne casser règles et ça fait partie
de nos comportements
la tension va subitement montée d'un
cran
le 11 novembre 1987 que s'est il passé
au juste dans le stationnement du poste
de police d'un quartier montréal hier
matin a priori les faits sont éloquents
un jeune noir de 19 ans anthony griffin
a été tué d'une balle dans la tête alors
que pourtant ils veulent oublier aux
policiers qui lui demandaient de ne plus
bouger système enfin de manoeuvre pour
tenter s'enfuir
un policier à ce moment atteignant la
victime à la tête
comment un policier peut-il avoir à ce
point la gâchette légère la sphère
greffe une soulève un tollé
cette fois des élus dénoncent le racisme
des policiers et les unités dont ils
jouissent
la pression populaire force la mise sur
pied de la commission bellemare
actuellement à la cmm ce sont des
officiers de police qui jugent du bien
fondé des pintes citoyens dans les cas
d'abus de pouvoir ou brutalité policière
une pratique qui manquerait de
crédibilité c'est de peindre un cycle à
l'opinion de tous de tous ceux qui sont
devant nous au départ et manque de
crédibilité
ces conclusions même dans la création
d'un comité de déontologie indépendant
et à la mise en place d'une formation
pour transformer les attitudes racistes
dont les organisations policières
c'était bon programme
c'était inutile il fallait le faire mais
ça va changer
la résistance du système sera plus forte
que les critiques les policiers s'oppose
farouchement au congédiement de l'agent
impliqué ils accusent leur chef de céder
aux pressions de groupes minoritaires
il y avait vraiment prise de conscience
qu'on a un problème alors on va demander
pourquoi avec tout ça est ce qu'on a eu
on les prises toujours avec les mêmes
problèmes et je pense que une des
raisons c'est que l'institution la
police et la fraternité des policiers de
montréal sont en deçà des institutions
avec beaucoup pouvoir qu'ils sont pas
transparents qui sont par le câble aux
citoyens la communauté noire ne
pardonnera jamais la faire greffer nu
la violente agression de rodney king par
des policiers de los angeles jettent une
lumière crue sur le problème du racisme
au tournant des années 90 c'est une
époque tumultueuse aux états unis durant
laquelle on assiste à l'émergence du
phénomène des gagne les échos s'en font
sentir jusqu ici on reproche souvent la
baule et et aux directions d'école de
sous-évaluer la montée de la violence
chez les jeunes et le phénomène des gags
le métro et les autobus
nos écoles sont moins sûrs qu'il ne
l'était la violence des jeunes est plus
épris des plus spontanée les agressions
contre les personnes augmentent et le
port du couteau quand ce n'est pas celui
des armes à feu peut donner lieu à de
véritables tragédies humaines la panique
commence à se répandre dans la
population
devant l'inquiétude générale la toute
première escouade anti gang est mise sur
pied
le problème est largement exagéré mais
devient que le prétexte pour élargir les
pouvoirs policiers avaient toujours eu
des cadres le moyen généralement blancs
mais ils ont pris le moment pour dire
que les gangs de rue moi c'est un vrai
problème
tout le monde et on va faire toute une
histoire pour lutter conte les jeunes en
pensant racisées
mais non c'est pas qu'on cible des
passants noir aussi dans le cadre de la
lutte anti gang survient un autre drame
la police confond marcellus françois un
jamaïcain de 24 ans avec le suspect
noirs et là bas par erreur d'une balance
les francs le confort et la mort de
marcellus françois ravive les tensions
raciales à montréal deux jours plus tard
des jeunes blancs s'en prennent
violemment à un groupe d'adolescentes
noire dans le quartier
hochelaga-maisonneuve
encore une fois les policiers s'acharne
sur les jeunes noirs qui sont pourtant
les victimes de l'agression
à l'issue d'une enquête interne sans
conclure à du racisme
le chef alain saint germain reconnaît
publiquement que la mort de marcellus
françois est le résultat d'une baby
cette opération a été un échec
elle remet en cause la crédibilité du
service de police dans ses relations
avec les citoyens et citoyennes et
soulève plusieurs questions sur nos
méthodes de travail
j'ai reconnu qu'on a fait une gaffe on a
fait une erreur il ya une personne
personne qui est décédée violemment par
un coup de feu qui ont été tirés par la
police
encore une fois la fraternité des
policiers mobilise ses membres deux
mille d'entre eux descendent dans la rue
pour réclamer sa démission
quand on est rendu à clé fois le giro
c'est plus calquée d'amasser entre les
gens du voyage et les intentions de
toute façon pourquoi ces personnes non
un mondialiste et j'appelle on veut
perdre gilles on veut plus qu'on a tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me rappelle du ministre de la
sécurité dans le temps mais schirrhein
qui m'avait dit mme saint germain ça
vous coûte cher votre transparent malgré
la résistance
le service de police amour ce virage
pour contrer le racisme dans ses rangs
dans les années 80 on a commencé à
s'interroger on a dit comment ça se fait
que la police à montréal elle est
masculin blanche 5 pieds 9 puis
française
on a fait en sorte de faire modifier les
normes d'hambourg alors ça ça le web
n'est pas aux femmes purgeant des
communautés ethnoculturelles
on a dérangé ont dérangé aussi à
l'intérieur de l'organisation parce
qu'on trouvait que on mettait beaucoup
d'efforts là dedans mais c'est pas
facile changer des mentalités
en dépit de ces efforts le problème va
empirer la petite escouade antigone
nouvellement créé la connaître nessakh
et multiplié ses interventions dans des
quartiers comme saint michel et
montréal-nord où stéphanie germain a
grandi ça peut être difficile à
comprendre pour certaines personnes pour
qui la police représente la sécurité
mais la police ne veut pas dire sécurité
pour tout le monde pour plusieurs jeunes
de montréal nord
la police est pas synonyme de sécurité
au tournant des années 2000 montréal
nord sera l'épicentre d'une guerre qui
va des serrages et cicatrices
au retour de nouvelles pratiques vont
s'ajouter à l'arsenal policier qui vont
devenir de puissants outils de profilage
rester avec nous dans les années 2000 la
menace du moment c'étaient les gangs de
rue et la police de montréal obtenu des
moyens considérables pour lutter contre
ce fléau de leurs résultats
plus de dix mille jeunes noirs ont été
fichés par la police
mon coeur commence à palpiter beckham
police sur la route
peu importe l'heure rien à me reprocher
et j'ai quand même des palpitations fait
que j'imagine que ça voudrait dire que
j'ai pas bien pour le poste mais quand
tu es en panique
tu dois appeler la police moi
aujourd'hui à 33 ans est ce que je vais
le faire
[Musique]
l'habitude que j'ai commencé à prendre
c'est de dire tout de suite mon cv aux
policiers je suis l'agent mon nom c'est
steven charles j'habite à telle adresse
je mets en interne et j'ai gardé des hec
dentelle de l'année voici mon emploi
voici qu'est ce que je fais puis c'est
aux mécanismes de défense que j'ai
appris à faire parce que
l'interpellation pour moi et je sentais
qu'elle pouvait aller dans une direction
[Musique]
stéphanie germées a grandi dans les hlm
de montréal-nord grandira - là ça veut
dire aussi
puis je parle pour moi puis parle aussi
pour la part des amis très jeune c'est
d'avoir une relation déjà étrange avec
la police quant au onze ans par exemple
cela soit sur le dossier du banc
la police t'approches si tu descends pas
deux là je donne un ticket puisse
continuer informative est arrêté
quoiqu'il nous dévisagent pourquoi on
sent qu'on est épié dans notre propre
quartier
[Musique]
on
son quartier les policiers l'appelle le
bronx à l'époque montréal nord souffre
de graves problèmes sociaux et de
pauvreté connaissent aussi vite à la
criminalité
c'est ce que les chercheurs appellent la
curie de les vitres brisées
l'idée est que tu vises des
environnements des quartiers des
populations où il ya des symptômes de
danger ou de désordre donc des fenêtres
brisées moquer ou des personnes
itinérantes et donc tu vises ces
quartiers là pour agir en prévention de
la commune est donc ça veut dire que tu
mets plus de police
[Musique]
tenter de prévenir le crime est une idée
séduisante mais qui va encore une fois
mettre dans la mire des policiers des
milliers de jeunes ont été des jeunes en
allant à l'école on nous aurons à payer
dans la criminalité
on faisait juste faire des choses que
n'importe quel jeune dans n'importe quel
parti devait faire c'est-à-dire prennent
et l'armée russe
j'avais l'impression parfois qu'on
marchait sur des oeufs sur des jeux
vidéo se promène dans un parc à la
police qui rôde un nouveau plan d'action
est adopté par le spvm flâner faire du
bruit des graffitis au total 26 gestes
d'incivilité deviennent autant de
raisons d'aider revenir pour la police
un policier en passant que bon il faut
prévenir la délinquance il faut prévenir
les désordres heures il va être plus
apte à arrêter un jeune noir qui
crachent qu'un blanc qui crachent donc
parce qu'on les autorise à surveiller
certains groupes y vont agir sur ces
incivilités de façon plus intense
[Musique]
soyez des jeunes qui finissent avec avec
un ticket sont pas l'argent pour le pays
sera masse en cours la moindre faute
phase des travaux communautaires lyon en
bus ils finissent avec un dossier
criminel peuvent pas travailler on est
parti d'un règlement municipal ont fini
avec la vie d'un jeune qui hypothéquait
[Musique]
milieu des années 2000 la grande
priorité c'est la lutte contre les gagne
grâce à près de 40 millions du fédéral
la petite escouade de six hommes un
compte maintenant 10 fois plus l'idée
c'était on va vous dire qu'on est là on
va vous montrer qu'on est là on va vous
rappelez vous maintenant vous avez plus
être tranquille parce qu'on va s'occuper
du problème des gangs de rue et donc on
va vous le dire en étant très présent en
faisant beaucoup d'interprétations
j'étais sorti avec mes amis et je sors
et je décide de les attendre devant le
bar sur seine est littéralement ils sont
sortis avec leurs fusils fait que
j'étais comme encerclé de trois endroits
ils t'ont menotté il ya plus personne
autour de toi mais il n'écoute pas je me
rappelle en ce moment là j'ai juste
répéter encore monstres une charge fini
en hausse à grains toi je réside à telle
adresse
moi je fais juste leur dire ça pour que
en espérant quelqu'un me coûtent tès
kick gens ils comprennent que sam aucun
rapport qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire plus loin une autre opération
coup de poing contre les gangs de rue à
montréal dit cette arrestation dans
l'ouest de l'iran ya moins d'une semaine
la police a arrêté 27 petits caïds à
montréal-nord et rivière des prairies le
noyau dur des gangs est constitué d'une
cinquantaine de personnes entre trois et
cinq cents autres et gravitent
possiblement au tour mais la police en
fiche 10000 la spvm a produit un
document pour les policiers qui
identifiait certains critères de jeunes
supposément délinquants guen de rue dans
laquelle il y avait des affaires traite
des clichés ok donc un des quatre
critères étaient bling bling et geniès
pas leurs critères étaient graffitis un
autre critère était habillement est
propre
qu'est-ce qui est loch vous dorer dans
north et des criminels
non j'ai des dents non c'est un bijou je
l'aimais je me sens bien avec ça fait
pas de moi c'est un criminel ou vernon
karla homolka veut pas de lock là
la lutte contre les incivilités la
surveillance et la guerre aux gagnants
vont produire un mélange toxique
ou 2008 des policiers aperçoivent un
groupe de jeunes considéré suspect qui
jouent aux dés il s'arrête pour
interpeller l'un d'eux
environ 60 secondes plus tard fredy
villanueva hondurien de 18 ans sans
casier judiciaire ni appartenance connus
ou gagne est abattu de deux coups de feu
par un policier
[Musique]
pour yaya rien fait
tc gainbourg sais pas quel taurus ans
moi ça a été mon premier réflexe est de
dire non vous vous trompez c'est
sûrement quelqu'un d'autre ne s'est pas
fait
puis après quand j'ai lu comme réalisé
en fait que
geste est vrai et ça a été vraiment un
gros chèque
[Musique]
ça a été terrible le lendemain de sa
mort montréal-nord s'embrase
[Musique]
ils sont pas liés seulement à la sphère
villanueva ses émules et la population
on avait marre se sentait harcelé il y
avait une ras-le-bol dans la population
qui a pu exploser au moment de la faire
vis de m chaque fois qu'ils aient des
rébellions 1 ap rising bayt mal al qods
c'est à cause de violences policières
toujours toujours toujours on sait tous
vu dans freddy qu'on s'est vus on s'est
reconnus là dedans parce qu'on se dise
on se dit finalement ça aurait pu
arriver à n'importe qui suite aux
émeutes ou ce qui est arrivé c'est de
dire que plus jamais plus jamais ya les
jeunes qui va perdre la vie aux mains
des forces policières
[Musique]
le spvm reconnaît sa part de
responsabilité dans le drame
pourtant dix ans plus tard les policiers
interpellent toujours les personnes
racisées de manière démesurée
après la pause le spvm promet de changer
encore je pense que c'est m
beau coup marketing depuis le début de
ce reportage on vous parle en
particulier du profilage envers les
personnes noires mais ceux qui se font
le plus interpellé en ce moment par le
spvm
ce sont les autochtones mon nom c'est
pierre paraire je suis franco ontarien
avec des m16 cricri je travaille à
montréal comme intervenait pour les
inclus
dr souvent que la police y arriver vous
pouvoir moi comme un autre sans abri
bois comme une personne différente loi
contre personne
la seule peine qui a développé le mandat
c6 c'est d'arrêter de donetsk est ou de
quoi que ce soit effectué vers le faire
annuler c'est comme si tu nous sors ce
qui est super je comprends les mots
sortis de la bouche de ces débats là une
réalité quotidienne
le profilage a aussi un visage
autochtones
les chiffres sont troublants ils sont
plus à risque d'être interpellée que
tous les autres ont soit plus d'un cas
des femmes et à une fréquence démesurée
nous avons maintenant des chiffres nous
avons des chiffres qui nous montrent ce
que les passes entre autochtones et
racisées nous en dit ou fait des
décennies
c'est à dire que la police les a salle
les oppriment les crimes analyse et
rennes cambuse non-citoyens promet non
humains
les constats des chercheurs sur les
disparités dans les interpellations ont
suscité de vives réactions devant la
commission de la sécurité publique de
montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je me sens mais comment
cette maj soviétique
[Musique]
vous
le racisme systémique est sur toutes les
lèvres
la pression vient de toutes parts pour
agir mais spvm dépose enfin sa solution
au problème du profilage la première
fois une politique vient avec une
interpellation doit être fondée
obligatoirement sur des faits
observables et sans motif
discriminatoire
moi je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions on essaie de comprendre un
fait si un fait pas observable c'est
quoi le fait que je sois noir c'est un
fait que quelqu'un peut observer donc
c'est un fait est observable
mais si les interpellations n'était pas
déjà fait son défaut observable été fait
sur quoi exactement
si à montréal que nous instaurons cette
nouvelle façon de faire je pense que
c'est un beau coup marketing et la
politique change absolument rien faesch
chargé rien changer la politique défini
ce qu'est une interpellation et fournit
des balises aux policiers pour s'en
servir mais le plus consternant pour les
critiques c'est qu'elles n'ajoute rien
qui n'ait pas déjà prévu dans la charte
des droits depuis des décennies et le
spvm le reconnaît pour oublier qu'on
écrit cette politique là ses propos des
juristes ce propos les citoyens mais
c'est bien pour les policiers pour
encadrer la pratique d'une
interpellation le fait que c'est clair
pour le principe on donne un cap qu'elle
on veut qu'ils évoluent ou qui
fonctionne dans le cadre de
l'interpellation mais c'est un aspect
important pour nous ça changera culturel
ailleurs au canada on va plus loin pour
tenter de mettre fin à la discrimination
posées par les interpellations
la nouvelle écosse les a carrément banni
parce qu'on les considère illégales en
alberta on doit dire aux personnes
interpellées qu'elles ne sont pas tenus
de répondre
toronto oblige ces policiers à remettre
sur le champ par écrit aux personnes
visées
les motifs de leur interpellation elles
ont chuté de manière draconienne dans
plusieurs juridictions où est ce qu'il
n'ya pas justement d'une interpellation
de routine mais il ya des enquêtes
policières qui se fond on devient plus
intelligent dans la façon justement
dominé nos enquêtes on ouvre nos
horizons
et puis souvent qu'est ce qu'on en fait
de faire avec les opérations de routine
c'est une partie de pêche
on sait jamais ce qu'on va pouvoir avoir
mais on tombe sur des gens que nous on
vous l'intercepter nous on veut pas
aller dans cette avenue l'on veut que
nos policiers faites-le face
l'interpellation de la bonne façon
basé sur des faits observables pixels
sans lien avec notre mission policière
parce qu'on croit foncières marquent
side est le lot des crimes des crimes
viols sous pourtant la recherche et deux
avis juridique au canada conclut au peu
d'utilité de l'interpellation pour
empêcher le crime
elle mène surtout à des abus de droit ce
serait utile d'avoir des caméras dans
tous nos efforts appartement d'avoir le
droit la police d'entrer à n'importe
quel moment
c'est toujours bon d'avoir plus
d'informations mais la question c'est
que est ce que c'est juste et avec les
incompréhensions on voit que
il faudrait non seulement les bannir
mais avoir le courage d'éliminer toutes
les pratiques discriminatoires
selon anne-marie livingstone que ça soit
la lutte aux gangs de rue
que ce soit les incivilités que ça soit
les contrôles d'identité que ça soit
l'investissement disproportionné de
ressources dans les quartiers à racisées
à montréal donc finir avec toutes ces
politiques qui vise de façon plus
intensive ces populations là je fais une
coalition d'organismes suggère de des
finances et la police est de réinvestir
dans des services à la communauté
elle propose de revoir de manière
radicale la mission même de la police il
ya encore la violence est encore là
qu'il a été dans nos communautés
ça ça veut dire que la police n'était
pas la solution mais nous ce qu'on dit
puis moi ce que je dit personnellement
c'est réinvestissant dans nos
communautés
ce que je parle de changement de
paradigme ces changements de vision il
faut réussir à transformer
fondamentalement la mission policière
à mon avis la manière suivante c'est que
plutôt que de se dire la chose la plus
importante de la police forcément juste
de lutter contre rennes je pense qu'on
peut dire la chose la plus importante
que de faire la pluie c'est de
contribuer à la sécurité des citoyens
et si vous interpellé de manière
disproportionnée et donc forcément
injuste
une partie de la population
produisez de l'insécurité au ridicule de
vous faites exactement contraire de
l'essence même de votre mission
le gouvernement s'engage dans une
direction fort différente 65 millions de
dollars qui seront investis il vient
d'annoncer de nouvelles ressources pour
accroître la lutte contre la criminalité
le spvm vient de lancer une nouvelle
escouade contre le trafic d'armes à feu
qui va cibler entre autres les quartiers
du nord de montréal
ceux qui dénoncent le profilage
craignent que l'histoire se répète
quand ils m'arrêtent moi je suis en
présence de deux personnes armées qui je
sais depuis cinq minutes cherche une
raison pour être dans mon intimité à
partir du moment où il parle je n'ai
plus de droit je n'aime pas de bénéfice
du doute
s'ils me tire dessus il aura une
histoire à raconter pour l'intensité de
ma faute je rêve au jour le nord le
droit d'être ordinaire
car vite dès que je rêve de ce jour
aussi où on n'a pas besoin de faire plus
pour exister et où l'autre juste le
simple fait d'être noir n'est pas un
fardeau de ces chenilles noir je suis
humain tout simplement
puis je suis la même chose que vous
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié de
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je me retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]